a lot has changed in the past three
weeks as you may have noticed we've
watched slack-jawed as professional
lawmakers attacked the rule of law we've
heard self-described anti-racism
activist embrace full-throated racism on
television we've seen people who call
themselves advocates for women destroy
the life of an actual woman for
political gain the country is all but
inverted during the debate over Brett
Cavanaugh's nomination it is
bewilderingly in case you're having
trouble keeping track of it all a
reminder that it was only a week ago
that Democrats argued that a second
Senate hearing into Brett Kavanaugh High
School record the one we saw was not
enough to find the truth we needed a
supplementary FBI investigation and we
needed it immediately there needs to be
an FBI investigation the FBI is an
agency of sworn trained law enforcement
officers they have the ability to do an
investigation have the independent
professionals of the FBI actually
investigate she has a right to have
those facts be developed by a
nonpartisan source like the FBI who
expert an FBI investigation is the only
way to answer some of these questions
uh-huh well it always struck us as a
mindless demand despite all the
hysterical demands for it everyone
involved had already given sworn
statements under the penalty of perjury
about what they knew about this story
the two people at the very center of it
had already testified before the
Congress on television but Cavanaugh's
life had been the subject of six
previous FBI probes not only was he
cleared in all six of them he was given
access to America's nuclear codes so we
knew all we were going to know about an
event that supposedly took place 37
years ago and that's why the FBI said it
had zero interest in getting involved
again and yet Democrats demanded a new
investigation anyway as you just saw and
then protesters screamed at poor Jeff
Flake in an elevator in the Senate until
he agreed with the Democrats so we got
the investigation it was supposed to
take a week everyone agreed on that but
it wrapped up in six days why because
there was nothing to find and almost
four
Cades after the fact or very few people
left to interview not surprisingly in
the end the FBI did not corroborate
Christine Ford's story you know what
that means don't you the FBI must be
involved in a cover-up yes a diabolical
secret plot orchestrated with their very
close allies in the Trump administration
that's what they're telling us the very
people whose days ago
we're telling us that the FBI is an
ethically unimpeachable organization the
ultimate tiebreaker now the FBI is part
of the deep state the investigation was
very limited this report is blatantly
and clearly incomplete our fears have
been realized our fears have been
realized this is not a thorough
investigation in your view is this a
fulsome and credible investigation it's
obviously a cover-up our fears have been
realized the FBI is working with the
Trump administration they always have
been it's a plot so secret we believe
the opposite is happening how's that for
clever others on the Left saying that
what we really need is for Brett
Kavanaugh to take a polygraph exam
because those are accepted by science
Senator Lindsey Graham of South Carolina
pointed out that the lie detector likely
just the first demand in a long list
watch why don't we dunk in the water see
people
maybe you'll believe he lied about how
much he drank in high school lady threw
ice in a party I'm excused being a bar
where he doesn't have the temperament
that he didn't handle being destroyed
well enough enough already
less fun why don't we just dunk him in
water and see if he floats it was good
enough in medieval France you know the
truth only one thing will truly be good
enough an investigation of some kind or
maybe a water dunking of some kind that
lasts at least through January 3rd 2019
that's when the new Congress will be
sworn in of course it's the real goal it
always has been
fortunately it looks like this ploy is
failing
win or lose Cavanaugh's nomination will
be voted on it looks like within a few
days it seems likely he'll be confirmed
but who knows and we won't know until
the moment the last vote is cast still
it's worth thinking about what the world
looks like once this is all over
after Cavanaugh's confirmation vote this
is a new country now what will it look
like well the left is accused President
Trump of overturning norms and
destroying institutions but as always
that is pure projection whatever they're
accusing you of is exactly what they're
doing and it's true in this case to the
left just mounted a full assault on our
justice system they thought nothing of
tossing out the presumption of innocence
you saw actual US senators say things
like the accused has an obligation to
prove himself innocent they said that
out loud and then they tried to use the
FBI as a weapon against their a
political opponents and not for the
first time the Obama administration did
the same think this will stop think
again thought leaders the extent that's
not an oxymoron on the left already
laying the groundwork to pack the courts
something that hasn't been tried since
the 1930s adding more Democrats to
change the balance the least democratic
small d-- democratic option available
it's only fair they'll tell you to
offset the theft of Merrick Garland's
seat on the Supreme Court and of course
the appointment of a teenage sex
offender going forward look for the
Toodee legitimize any decisions written
by Brett Kavanaugh from the court or
even any decisions in which he is the
majority some states may just decide to
ignore the Supreme Court
sound fair fetched far-fetched to you
maybe maybe not look what's happening in
California right now lawmakers in that
state the largest state in the Union
have already made it a crime for
citizens in California to insist assist
in the enforcement of any federal
immigration law California is in effect
in open revolt against the laws of the
United States
suppose the supreme court were to try to
crack down on that it's not impossible
to imagine California is simply refusing
to comply because Brett Kavanaugh sits
on the court
it's edicts are illegitimate that could
happen and that by the way is what
crisis actually looks like so get ready
for that